[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde
à la une ce soir donald trump n'est pas
encore battu mais on s'interroge déjà
sur la presse le trump isme petit lui
survivre et faut-il forcément tous
rejetés dans cette autre façon de faire
de la politique
l'autre inconnue elle est liée à joe
biden lui même quelle est sa vision des
relations internationales l'europe et la
france doivent être forcément se réjouir
de sa possible aux victoires de tout
cela on débat avec notre grand témoin ce
soir l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères hubert védrine
enfin le fonctionnement de l'espace
schengen à nouveau sous le feu des
critiques après l'attentât de nice
emmanuel macron demande sa remise à plat
et un renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières et il fait un lien entre
immigration clandestine et terrorisme
cela fait réagir vous le verrez vous
même vous pouvez réagir commenter cette
actualité sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le mot-clé cvr et pour débattre de cette
élection présidentielle américaine et
des leçons à en tirer j'accueille ce
soir hubert védrine bonsoir
bonjour vous êtes ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères sous lionel jospin
diplomate auteur de nombreux ouvrages le
dernier en date et après on en parlera
dans la seconde partie de cette émission
et puis à mes côtés également à mme crac
bonsoir madame vous êtes membre de
l'institut open diplomatie historienne
spécialiste des états unis et puis nous
serons également en direct des etats
unis justement un cri charvet rallye
journaliste pour le quotidien suisse le
temps
bonsoir richard et à tout à l'heure voir
les états unis ne connaissent donc
toujours pas officiellement le nom de
leur futur président joe biden a pris
l'avantagé mais rien n'est joué pour
l'instant d'autant que donald trump
compte se battre jusqu'au bout alors le
trump isme vit-il ses dernières heures
on voit cela avec stéphane blakowski
bonsoir stéphane bonsoir clément un
bonsoir à vous alors si j'ai bien
compris stéphane si j'ai bien compris
clément les élections viennent de
prouver que trump conserve encore de
nombreux partisans états unis donc même
s'il était battu
eh bien le trump isme pour autant ne
devrait pas disparaître
alors comment est ce que vous expliquez
qui conserve autant de partisans bah
déjà il faut se souvenir que pendant les
trois premières années de son mandat
donald trump a eu d'excellents résultats
économiques un ses adversaires le
présenter comme un imbécile clown
incapable de diriger le pays
et puis en réalité train de tâter des
miracles alors le mot miracle n'est pas
de moi c'était dans le titre d'un
article du monde publié en mai 2010 mais
de mai 2010 mais voyez les surprises du
miracle économique américain chômage le
plus bas croissance au plus haut donc
finalement il ne sait pas si mal
débrouillé en tout cas dans le domaine
économique
alors sauf que ces bons résultats
économiques ils ont été un petit peu
plombé par la crise du coc vide et c'est
plus de 200000 morts aux etats unis
alors oui oui là vous marquez un point
c'est pas faux mais en même temps
puisque je suis là un petit peu pour me
faire l'avocat du diable devrait quand
même préciser qu'aux états unis il ya un
taux d obésité considérable 40% des
adultes sont obèses et c'est bien sûr un
facteur extrêmement aggravant alors en
france on a 17 % seulement de bézy t
alors si je vous comprends bien on a un
peu diaboliser injustement donald trump
alors attention j'ai pas dit injustement
mais ce qui est faux cas certain c'est
que lui on a que trump a été diabolisé
par les élites culturelles américaines
les stars d'hollywood bound by donne
mais ça on s'en fiche un peu mais mais
surtout diabolisé par les universités et
puis aussi par les médias pour ce qui
est des universités on suit fin
régulièrement en france un débat
régulièrement sur la can cette
culture-là récemment on se bat pour
défendre les minorités dans l'est
l'université mais c'est parfois que ccif
on déboulonne les statuts on sent
surtout les propos qu'on estime sexistes
ou racistes
on excommunie même ceux qui ne
respectent pas le politiquement correct
or or quand on fait des sondages à ce
propos aux états unis vous allez voir un
article du courrier international qui
reprenait un article américain bien une
majorité d'américains soit un peu là
c'est en fait ce politiquement correct
ils sont lassés de voir que la liberté
d'expression qui est si importante aux
états unis est ils sont qui sont
saoulés par le politiquement correct et
filles pour ce qui est des médias
on en parlait hier sur ce plateau
l'immense majorité des grands médias
sont systématiquement opposé à trump il
ya une étude qui a été menée harvard qui
est publié là dans le washington post
qui n'est pas du tout partisan de trump
et qui donnait ce chiffre 80 11 % des
articles ou des prises de parole sur
trump dans les réseaux lire donc les
grands réseaux sont le fait d'un point
de vue négatif donc pour illustrer un
petit peu ça je vous propose d'écouter
le correspondant du new york times
enfants new york times en france qui
s'appelle adam desitter je vous le
propose de l'écouter quand il parle de
trump voilà le ton sur lequel que le ton
qu'il envoie pardon c'est sûr su prouver
que la stratégie de crohn depuis le
début c'est d'edf d'enflammer les
passions des gens d'inciter les gens à
jouir pleinement de leur haine que ce
soit pour les immigrés pour les
mexicains pour les noirs crunch jouent
sur la haine
alors qu'est ce qui vous choque dans ses
propos vous les trouvez excessif c'est
sûr c'est prouvé sur les progrès les
bords disons que pour à genlis et pas
forcément très très objectif mais en
fait ça nous choque pas nous français
sommes en français quand on entend
quelqu'un comme ça s'emballe et un petit
peu sur 30 mai pour mieux termes mesurés
le parti pris d'une partie de la presse
américaine les grands médias américains
et down the sitter en l'occurrence vous
propose de regarder
l'article qui l'a consacré à
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit donc voilà
comment l'article était titré la police
française à bas un homme dans la rue
après une attaque au couteau
vous voyez on a le sentiment que pour
lui
le fait que la police ait tué l'assassin
prend plus de place que le meurtre du
professeur comme si c'était presque une
bavure donc on a vraiment l'impression
que pour une partie en tout cas de
l'opinion américaine il ya quelque chose
de choquant là dedans comme nous on est
choqués ont l'impression que les élites
américaines intellectuels sont vraiment
déconnecté en tout cas les
préoccupations des gens ordinaires
évidemment trump lui a su profiter de sa
s'est présenté comme le héros de la
working class comme celui qui tenait
tête aux élites et dépend d'elle et jean
monnet et puis évidemment par ses
propres excès à lui il a creusé un peu
plus encore le fossé entre on va dire
l'amérique d'en haut et l'amérique d'en
bas donc la finale on la question qui se
pose si joe biden a été finalement élu c
est ce qu'il sera capable au cours de
son mandat de combler ce fossé entre ces
deux amériques et pouvoir rassembler
enfin les américains merci à vous
stéphane hubert védrine on vient de voir
dans la chronique de stéphane un peu ce
qui a fait le succès de donald trump ce
positionnement en homme politique anti
système
si on devait d'abord théorisé ce qu'est
le tropisme comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait le définir selon vous d'abord
je pense que c'est un phénomène qui
vient de loin aux états unis je pense
que trump aura été une caricature mais
pas une aberration
ils représentent au moins la moitié de
l'amérique latine amérique il ya eu des
phénomènes genre tea party il ya
longtemps et le fait que les classes
populaires puis les classes moyennes et
décroché depuis longtemps dix ans la
mondialisation financer bon pour les
chinois mais pas pour nous on l'a vu à
travers beaucoup de phénomènes c'est
vrai aussi en europe sinon il aurait pas
eu de le briser devriez et donc après
y'a trump il faut essayer d'oublier un
moment d dans l'analyse sa personnalité
il est effrayant sur beaucoup de plantes
en personnalité il ya sa personnalité de
sa politique
le bilan et puis est-ce que c'est un
phénomène passager c'est pas le cas
le trump heist et d'une composante du
peuple américain maintenant ça va rester
c'est à dire si jamais il est battu à la
présidentielle le tropisme il ya
toujours survivra oui bien sûr mais sur
quelle forme
c'est un populisme américain c'est des
gens qui détestent les élites de la côte
est et la côte ouest
je vois le chef du site et qui est très
important parce que sur le faire du
politiquement correct on est à la limite
du fascisme corps humain
comportement des différents groupes
menée par des activistes et c'est
l'interdiction de parler et c'est le
fait qu'ils aient une réaction du petit
andy politique identitaire en france ça
veut dire plutôt des gens d'extrême
droite en fait identity politique
s'était immiscée au contraire des genres
de gauche qui pense que l'identité est
la clé de la lecture de la société ce
qui re défendre les minorités ceux qui
auraient la isla en or pur ou en france
c'est pas des gens d'extrême droite
ils se nourrissent pas n'a en fait non
donc c'est des mouvements ultra
gauchistes qui se servent de ça qui expo
qui est important en france les névroses
américaine donc trump ça va rester
notamment si le sénat reste à majorité
républicaine même et qu'abidal est en
fait dans le parti républicain les les
républicains classique à l'époque george
bush père par exemple il n'y avait plus
donc c'est une composante durable je
pense anne crac vous partager ce point
de vue parce que pour que le trump isme
survivent à donald trump ça veut dire
qu'il doit être repris à son compte par
le parti républicain il ya quand même un
peu de lignes dans ce parti je suis
d'accord avec monsieur monsieur védrine
jusqu'à un certain point
parce que bon ce qu'il faut voir avec le
chanteur sait que l'homme avait un noyau
dur de soutien de supporteurs qui se
montait à environ 40% et qui représente
ce populisme américain dont on vient de
parler à l'instant et qui s'adresse qui
comporte qui comprend des gens qui rêve
d'une amérique qui n'existe plus depuis
longtemps
ça c'est un peu la base de l'or de l'or
de l'or populiste n'avait une amérique
on peut faire tout ce qu'on veut et où
on est les rois de
si on est blanc en tout cas et si on est
les rois du pays au dessus de ses 40% de
votants pour lui en l'occurrence il ya
eu environ 20 % de gens dont la
principale préoccupation était
l'économie effectivement l'économie
américaine se portaient très bien avant
la pandémie
c'était pas tout à fait du aa jobs
s'était aussi dû à obama qui avait géré
les normes crise de 2008
extrêmement bien et par un effet
mathématique il ya eu un tel une telle
récession en 2008 qu'au bout de dix ans
tout ça s'était résorbée et là et le le
chômage avait complètement avait diminué
jusqu'à un point qui n'avait pas connu
depuis des années et des années par les
blancs et pour les noirs d'air comme
pour tout le monde
absolument mais ce qui est paradoxal
c'est qu'on se retrouve sur le plan
économique avec un donald trump
antilibérale ce qui est très loin de la
position historique du parti républicain
et on se retrouve avec un parti
démocrate qui défend lui le libéralisme
économique
oui absolument oui ça c'est une c'est
quelque chose que les économistes
américains soulignaient à l'envi puisque
quand les républicains n'étaient pas au
pouvoir par exemple ils poussaient des
hauts cris au sujet du déficit américain
maintenant qu'ils sont au pouvoir
le déficit de la planche à billets etc
mais moi ce que je voudrais dire je
voudrais me faire l'avocat du diable si
vous me le permettez pas ce que vous
avez dit que vous êtes s'était fait
l'avocat du diable
je pense que le tourisme tel qu'on l'a
connu avec ses excès est au contraire en
voie de disparition et là je me lance
dans l'avenir parce que il est composé
de gens qui comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
croit en une amérique qui n'existe plus
depuis longtemps et ils vont finir par
s'en rendre et vous vous entendez moi
part ça c'est quoi c'est ce nationalisme
poussé à l'excès c'est la religion la
religion poussé à l'excès
une espèce de une espèce de sentiment de
camaraderie entre les hommes blancs
entre en particulier par opposition aux
femmes c'est amérique va forcément
disparaître pour des questions
démographiques et pour des questions de
diversité ethnique
hubert védrine il c'est vrai mais
l'amérique vu par le new york times
n'existe pas non plus et celle de
washington post n'existe pas non plus
parce que explique stéphane dans cette
année et l'amérique qui idéalisent les
européens en croyant que le cauchemar
trump étant peut-être fini on va revenir
une sorte d'entente idéal d'avant ça
n'existe pas non plus en fait donc
l'amérique est tout à fait capable de
d'inspirer de le susciter des fantasmes
tout à fait contradictoires et la
démographie n'explique pas tout parce
qu'il ya un pourcentage important des
latinos qui ont voté trop un peu par
exemple oui et quand même 10 % des noirs
malgré tout qui en vaut d'être un bon
donc c'est plus complet qu'il ya une
tendance historique je sais bien ils
veulent pas abandonner cette
prédominance tous les ans mais
historiquement non mais je pense que le
trump heist va rester pas sur la forme
trump non avec sa grossièreté ses excès
et ses draps mais quand même c'est une
composante populiste le populisme est
présent à peu près dans tous les pays
occidentaux
c'est les gens qui croient plus à la
mondialisation où l europe telle qu'on
leur a raconté ce n'est pas forcément
une choses monstrueuses
en tout cas tout le monde va devoir
tenir et d'ailleurs le bail donne pour
réussir à avoir le score qu'il atteint
il va sans doute être président il a
quand même récupéré une partie du
discours sur les jobs en amérique pour
essayer de récupérer une partie des
déchirures et blanc à l'est de la chine
serait la même que celle que trump a
mis en place en gros et en tout cas on
va en parler après décès mieux les états
unis comme en fait je pense que ce
serait ni obama ni clinton c'est autre
chose
ils ne s'intègrent démocrate un peu plus
populiste justement et s'il est élu il
faut quand même voir que comme je le
disais tout à l'heure à monsieur une
grande partie enfin une partie
importante de personnes qui ont voté
transforme cette fois ci est la dernière
fois était des gens qui avaient voté
pour obama
dans ma peau ma propre famille en
amérique
il ya eu des gens qui ont voté deux fois
pour obama et après ils ont voté comme
un seul homme pour trame et cette fois
ci encore donc c'est plus compliqué que
ça aussi parce que des gens qui
souffrent qui sont capables de voter
pour obama et après 3,9 il faut il faut
examiner ce que ça signifie bon alors on
n'a peut-être pas le temps d'en parler
mais on peut penser que obama a déçu une
partie de ces petites gens comme on les
appelle comme l'a appelé malheureusement
comme les a appelés malheureusement les
appelait les déplorables
ah oui la petite petite j'avais dit
déplorable c'est des plombs se sont
sentis trahis par obama parce que pour
le dire très vite bien entendu ils se
sont rendus compte qu obama a été et est
bien noir ou à moitié noir mais en fait
c'était un blanc de par son comportement
à tous les niveaux et c'était surtout un
blanc un membre de l'élite ça il n'avait
pas compris tout de suite je crois on va
on va prendre la direction des états
unis pour aller voir richard galy a
évoqué justement avec lui les partisans
de donald trump richard vous êtes à
arris beurre je crois en pennsylvanie ça
fait plusieurs jours maintenant que vous
suivez la fin de cette campagne
présidentielle pour votre journal suisse
le temps
comment réagissent les partisans de
donald trump à la perspective d'une
défaite de leur leader eh bien écoutez
je pourrais vous en dire plus tout à
l'heure puisque la raison pour laquelle
je suis harris perdre c'est pour
rencontrer les avocats du camp tron qui
viennent de déposer des recours ici à la
cour suprême de l'état de pennsylvanie
alors pour vous donner un détail
important quand même je ne porte pas de
masque presque je suis dans la garderie
spurs derrière moi qui est totalement
désert parce que le trafic ferroviaire
aux états unis est presque vide en ce
moment donc voilà l'explication sinon
dans la rue tout le monde ici
porte le masque alors les partisans de
donald trump et bien on en a eu un petit
exemple hier à philadelphie il a est la
grande métropole de pennsylvanie il y
avait une manifestation de danty trolls
qui portaient tous un sweat shirt jaune
sur le thème tous les votes doivent être
comptés il y avait des hélicoptères dans
le ciel beaucoup de police dans les rues
et il ya eu des bandes des lecteurs de
preuves qui sont venus pour dire que
selon eux le scrutin en pennsylvanie
était volé je me suis approché d'eux je
leur ai demandé mais qu'est ce que vous
avez comme élément contrer tout pour
parler de ces fraudes est ce qui vous
avez vu des urnes être dérobées donnez
moi des éléments ils n'ont rien en
réalité toutes les plaintes qui sont
déposées sont des plaintes déposées par
rapport à ces fameux vote par
correspondance sur lesquelles la cour
suprême fédérale américaine s'était
prononcé en autorisant le dépouillement
en pennsylvanie jusqu'à vendredi
on le voit donc très mal commencé
recours pourrait faire et rallier dans
un débat comme celui ci le décomptage
des voix qui se peut que je suis encore
en ce moment trump reste en avance mais
avec une avance qui a considérablement
fondu depuis hier merci à vous richard
anne crac contentant apple voilà le
récit un que nous faire effet reverdit
de l'état d'esprit des partisans de m il
ya un risque d'insurrection vous pensez
aux états unis si jamais donald trump
devait être déclarés battus ça dépend ce
que vous entendez par insurrection
insurrection générale n'ont certainement
pas mais y aura certainement des
bagarres oui certainement des bagarres
on a vu des magasins les endroits chics
se barricader il y aura des bagarres et
le problème c'est que tout le monde a
des armes
et qu'en plus les faits news circulent
tellement sur les réseaux sociaux
je peux vous donner un exemple très
concret dans une toute petite ville de
l'oregon où habite ma famille encore une
fois un bruit a couru qu'une bande
antifa c'est à dire des anti fasciste
allait venir tout de suite une milice
locale s'est armé jusqu'aux dents et
s'est positionné dans les rues de cette
petite ville pour attendre les antifas
et éventuellement et armés jusqu'aux
dents
or c'était évidemment une fausse
nouvelle mais voilà bon c'est possible
il varie drink quand on voit comment
donald trump conteste les résultats il
le fait toutes les heures sur son compte
twitter en ce moment depuis depuis hier
il représente une menace réelle pour la
démocratie américaine
vous pensez j'en sais rien j'en sais pas
plus que vous on voit la même chose je
pense une bataille d'arrière garde qui
peut durer pendant des semaines
et puis là il disant il ya une
exagération pathologique aux états unis
du du rôle des juristes à remarcher en
plus un bon ça peut durer très très
longtemps là où il y aurait vraiment une
crise historique comparable à rien dans
l'histoire du tennis et si le 20 janvier
au 21 g + 20 21 20 janvier ils sont pas
d'accord sur qui doit aller à la maison
blanche
sinon si ça dure des semaines on regarde
bien et c'est vrai vous l'avez dit c'est
là de l'attention la haine la division
l'édition géographique
on peut presque avoir des pays qui
deviennent indépendants les uns des
autres c'est des étapes des munichois
l'armement en fait tout ça oui mais je
n'en sais pas plus que vous encore une
fois mais je crois pas je crois là la
bataille pendant des semaines je crois
pas la maxi crise on se retrouve dans
les situations du venezuela comme mais
bon je suis pas le puits oui ce qu'on
peut ce dont on peut avoir peur puisque
on peut s'attendre à tout les excès de
la part de ton nom de chantepie là quand
même à montrer
assez brillamment si je sais que pendant
ces onze semaines pendant lesquelles il
a encore il était encore président des
états unis et peut faire ce qu'il veut
il peut gouverner par décrets on
pourrait imaginer un scénario dans
lequel il ya une espèce de provocation
on invente une provocation il peut
commencer une guerre avec les rangs
quelque chose soit alors à ce moment là
on serait dans un cas de figure où tout
d'un coup tout le peuple américain à
toute la population américaine de soul
tiendra fin c'est une c'est une c'est de
la politique fiction mais avec avec toi
on est dans on est souvent dans la
politique fiction
vous ajoutez un mot puisque je ne sais
pas si on a l'occasion d'en parler après
c'est tellement fascinant qu'on pu en
parler pendant des heures c'est
tellement étrange étonnant dans tout ça
mais la vraie question
on est à paris dans la vraie question
c'est qu'est ce que doivent faire des
européens
on va en parler et polaires voulait dire
là à l'heure actuelle ou non mais après
dans l'avenir pas uniquement être
complètement fasciné subjugué groupies
de l'img l'autre etc
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire on doit
dépasser fait quand même quatre
générations qui ont vécu dans un monde
occidental garant qui protégé par les
états unis c'était un trio mais il est
peut-être temps de se demander ce qu'on
doit faire nous pas uniquement attendre
les résultats du match voyait enfin vous
vous entendez de prendre plus de
distance plus d'autonomie
j'ai l'impression que c'est ce que cela
sous-entend oui mais bon pas dans
l'hostilité je pense que les européens
devrait enfin comprendre que pour
défendre leurs intérêts vitaux dans le
monde tel qu'il est qui est chaotique
il faut qu'ils s'affirment plus il
pourra en parler dans la deuxième partie
de l'émission et mais pour parler de
l'europe
le tropisme s'est déjà propagé dans le
monde en quelques sortes notamment en
europe
vous pensez qu'il ya un risque de dérive
autoritaire de certaines démocraties en
europe avec des leaders qui s'inspire de
donald trump vous pensez que c'est une
menace réelle qui se limite pas à
quelques pays en europe de l'est ou en
europe mais moi je fais pas de morale
sur la dérive on est on est qui pour
juger la dérive on n'est pas le new york
times ont je pense que ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est les des classes
populaires puis des classes moyennes qui
ne croient plus qu'on leur a dit sur la
mondialisation un mondialisation
heureuse qui ne croient plus beaucoup
moins en tout cas son avis sur la
construction européenne
c'est le résultat des politiques menées
pendant 30 ou 40 ans donc c'est pas la
peine de les excommunier après des tirs
d'essai rebonds contre le populisme
comme l'eau bénite contre les vampires
ça sert à rien va justement écoutez à ce
propos
écoutez à ce propos ce que disait arnaud
montebourg ce matin de donald trump
c'était sur france inter si on enlève la
question de nos propres intérêts et du
regard qu'on porte il y as pour moi dans
la très forte résistance emprunte un
plébiscite pour la force
c'est à dire qu'en fait derrière la
force il y à la protection de toutes les
couches sociales qui ont été abandonnés
dans le système économique mondialisé
puis 20 ans et dans le protectionnisme
que défend trump qui est dans ses
engagements qu'il a respecté
donc il a écouté son peuple il a
respecté ses propres engagements et il a
exercé d'une façon erratique chaotique
presque funambulesque clownesque presse
pourrait-on dire vu d'ici il a exercé la
force la force y compris contre
l'économie vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que dit arnaud montebourg sur donald
trump
je suis pas en désaccord en tout cas
parce que je pense qu'il met le doigt
sur une vraie attitude et des peuples
dans toute la sphère démocratique est
alors le protectionnisme les gens
hurlent contre le protectionnisme comme
si c'était une contrepoids ligier
richier terme et le fait que les peuples
veille et de protéger c'est une banalité
en fait il faut voir comment ils veulent
pas forcément se renfermer les
lamentations sur le repli sur soi c'est
du même ordre sert à rien de dire ça ils
peuvent l'être protéger
ils veulent bien être dans un monde
ouvert si c'est pas c'est pour pas
atteinte à la protection
donc je suis assez d'accord et c'est
pour ça que je pense que le traumatisme
sous une forme moins on a vu le gars
disent on va survivre comme une force
politique et ça peut exister à peu près
partout y compris en europe
sinon il n'y a pas de brigitte et à la
peine d'aller chercher en europe de
l'est avec brigitte si on n'intègre pas
cette donnée fans crac
il a beaucoup de défauts donald trump
mais il a quand même une qualité c'est
qu'il tient ses promesses en tout cas il
a tenu la plupart des promesses
électorales qui l'avait fait aux
américains et ça ça ça a joué aussi non
oui sans doute
écoutez moi je pense que ce qu'il faut
sur ce sur quoi il faut s'appesantir
maintenant c'est comprendre que rien ne
sera plus jamais comme avant parce que
même si byron gagné il a gagné à mon
avis il ne pourra pas raccommoder les
déchirures kbc pardon il va essayer le
mari concilier oui non mais je pense pas
que s'ils voulaient le monde a changé
l'amérique a changé les forces qui les
forces vives américaines ont forcément
changé à cause de choï en bien et en mal
et même les gens du new york times vont
devoir
changer les titres de leurs articles
pour qu'il reflète plus sérieusement ce
qui suit dans l'article parce qu'une des
choses qui se passent très souvent dans
les journaux américains maintenant c'est
que les titres sont une chose et puis
après quand on lit l'article c'est
complètement différent s'est indigné que
ils l ont changé très rapidement devant
la halle dans la dédiant un plan d'eau
donc moi je pense qu'il faut il faut
surtout essayer de comprendre qu'est ce
que va devenir le monde et surtout
qu'est ce que va devenir l'europe qui
est quand même la plus grande puissance
économique du monde dans l'actuelle un
plus grandes puissances est une entité
économique
oui une pige en soit ces cliques mental
mais justement elle a tellement de tous
par sa diversité même elle finit par
ressembler à la mairie am il faut la
suivre la volonté d'être une puissance
ah bah oui et pour départager parcelles
ont fait peur là pour ça il faut
peut-être un homme fort malheureusement
on n'en veut pas la pub merci merci
beaucoup on craint d'être jeune et sur
le plateau de ça vous regarde hubert
henno vous restez avec nous parce que
vous êtes notre grand témoin ce soir
[Musique]
alors on va parler dans quelques
instants de votre dernier livre 1 qui
essaient de tirer les leçons de la crise
sanitaire mondiale mais d'abord on a
envie d'entendre un peu l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères sur joe
biden richard vers lui et toujours avec
moins directe de philadelphie alors
richard vous vous avez donc suivi cette
fin de campagne présidentielle aux états
unis qu'est ce que l'on sait précisément
du programme international de joe biden
y en a très peu parlé de politique
internationale puisque la fin de la
campagne a été essentiellement consacrée
à ratisser les états clés qu'il est
d'ailleurs en train d'obtenir mais ce
que l'on cite son agenda diplomatique
c'est essentiellement trois choses la
première c'est qu'il a promis d'être
aussi ferme que donald trump sur la
chine alors ses adversaires disent que
ce ne sera pas le cas qu'il n'est pas
capable d'avoir la force la ténacité
d'un treuil on verra la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il veut réconcilier joe biden
les états unis avec ses partenaires
atlantique c'est à dire avec les alliés
au sein de l'otan n'oublions pas que
dans sa carrière de sénateur il a été
longtemps le président de la commission
du sénat chargée des affaires étrangères
donc il
il sera sans doute vis-à-vis de l'europe
dans une position peut être pas de grand
réconciliateur mais en tout cas dans une
position de main tendue pour discuter
d'affaires stratégiques et enfin dernier
point qui est très important c'est le
multilatéralisme
là on peut faire confiance à joe biden
pourrait être davantage investi dans les
institutions bilatérales
vous savez que les états unis viennent
officiellement de quitter la corde paris
sur le climat
ça c'est un point très important on peut
s'attendre à ce qu'une amie station by
fun assez vite reviennent à la table des
discussions et parapher cet accord sur
le climat que barack obama avait accepté
lors de la conférence de paris en 2015
merci beaucoup richard verdier hubert
védrine on entend ce que dit richard
verdi mais est-ce qu'il faut vraiment
s'attendre un retour au monde d'avant si
joe biden est élu président des états
unis
non d'abord le monde d'avant on sait pas
quand c
avant trump entre d'accord moi je pense
que si c'est bye donne avec des équipes
démocrates qui vont être en place petit
à petit pendant et d'autres mois qui
viennent c'est pas l'époque clinton
il peut pas jouer la carte de la
mondialisation heureuse triomphante
acquise états unis qui font que ce
qu'ils veulent dans tout ça c'est pas la
carte obama parce qu obama par exemple
été très réticent sur les interventions
extérieures alors que les démocrates en
général sont assez pour revenir à une
politique de propagation des valeurs
donc de la démocratie donc les
interventions extérieures mais là il a
quand même cette ambition a priori de
refaire des états unis un peu les
gardiens de la paix dans le monde
seulement il faut comprendre ça c'est
leur venir un leadership américain
ça peut conduire si ça tourne mal à la
guerre en irak y est mais ça peut
conduire aussi à des relations apaisées
normal avec les différents alliés dans
les salles idées reçues leadership il a
fait défaut sur certains dossiers
notamment l'accord sur le climat de
paris il ya des points très précis où ce
qu'a dit brydon et le contraire de ce
cap et trump ci vient dans la corde
paris tant mieux s'il réussit avec les
européens l'accord sur l'iran tant mieux
si des blocs l'om c'est tant mieux s'il
revient dans le match quand on a besoin
pour évaluer l'an prochain toutes les
politiques pour le pandémie tant mieux
mais n'empêche que les etats-unis
reviendront pour exercer leur leadership
ils peuvent pas le faire comme s'il n'y
avait pas les émergents comme si ce
n'est pas la chine
et comme ce n'est pas la volonté de
l'europe d'avoir quand même un petit peu
d'autonomie sur ces questions donc il
peut pas faire comme avant et comme il a
dû changer le discours sur le le
commerce et le reste pour récupérer une
partie de l'électorat qui avaient été
ses troupes il peut pas revenir au libre
échange aveugle en dix ans la
mondialisation à outrance c'est bien
c'est comme c'est pour ça que les peuls
les classes populaires et moyennes ont
décroché donc il y aura ce ne sera pas
un allié le commander facile sur les
questions de le commerce sur les
questions de par exemple de gaf a vous
êtes en train de dire que pour l'europe
une victoire de jo baiia n'est pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle non plus
c'est une bonne nouvelle sur les cinq ou
six points que j'ai énuméré je suis pas
binaire mais en revanche c'est pas un
monde totalement facile parce que
les démocrates pas plus que les autres
ne veulent d'une europe qui s'affirme et
vous pensez bien que les gars fans ne
vont pas qu'ils font tout pour qu'il y
ait pas de mise en oeuvre google amazon
facebook en fait tout ce qu annonce
thierry breton est très bien il faudrait
le faire mais les gars façon déchaîné
contre sa les démocrates devront
soutenir les gars fin donc avoir une
vision qui soit pas un noir et blanc qui
soit pas binaire il ya des éléments très
intéressante et utile pour le monde si
c'est un bail pour le monde et pour
l'europe c'est c'est pas commode donc
faut que l'europe prenne les devants pas
attendre passivement
il faut avoir un agenda il faut pas
rater le rendez-vous by donne pour les
européens on va écouter justement jean
yves le drian qui était ce matin sur
europe 1 et qui évoquait justement c'est
après trump dans les relations europe
etats unis depuis quatre ans il y a eu
une évolution on ne reviendra pas au
statu quo ante et on ne reviendra pas
dans une espèce de bon vieux temps de la
relation transatlantique le monde a
bougé depuis quatre ans et ce qui a
bougé aussi c'est le fait que l'europe à
affirmer sa souveraineté depuis quatre
ans il vous faudra reconstruire
désormais une nouvelle relation
transatlantique
il ya un point qui est intéressant aider
l'europe à construire à affirmer sa
souveraineté depuis quatre ans
finalement il a c'est un peu un mal pour
un bien donald trump il a servi
d'électrochoc à l'europe ont peut-être
d'une prise de conscience du besoin de
pouvoir compter que sur soi et pas
forcément toujours sur les états unis
disons que le comportement de trump
autant l'aspect personnel que les
politiques ça ils ont encouragé
l'europe est allé un peu dans le sens qu
indique jean-yves le drian et c'est
assez vrai ce qu'il dit mais c'est pas
assez
les européens sont tellement attachés à
leur situation d'avant ce que j'appelle
moi depuis vingt ans les bisounours dans
le monde jurassic park
ça c'est les européens attachés à notre
confrère jean quatremer qui dit les
européens sont des herbivores dans un
monde carnivores illicite un ministre
allemand qui a dit ça ah c'était encore
mieux qu'un ministre est que ma formule
à moi qui était typiquement française
sur les bisounours il a dit attention
c'est remarquable et l'ancien président
du spd que dit ça donc s'il ya des
éléments
intéressant que mon avis jean yves le
drian soudaine il a raison mais on est
très loin du compte quand même immense
majorité des européens contre le redis
faut quand même repas recoloniser le
monde mais il faut quand même qu'on soit
respecté par le congrès américain par
poutine par la chine
par ailleurs deux gagnent par netanyahou
par les saoudiens par les trafiquants
d'émigration clandestine par les gars et
compagnie bon les gens vont bien je dis
voilà mon dieu si on pouvait rester
protégé par les américains donc la
france a marqué des points il ya la
vision française de l'europe a marqué
des points c'est vrai mais elle n'est
pas partagée par tous
yahia litres il ya une tribune qui a été
dessiné par la ministre allemande de la
défense je pense que vous l'avez vu dans
politique au contraire lui voilà le
titre american aurait pas encore besoin
des états unis elle explique que à ses
yeux aux yeux de l'allemagne est là et
il faut pouvoir compter sur le bouclier
nucléaire américain il faut voilà on est
pas on n'est pas dans une vision
partagée franco allemande un bon pour
aller de l'avant vers une droite
polymérique je pense pas que le
représente l'ensemble des points de vue
allemand et c'est étonnant le petit
qu'elle a fait maintenant parce que
quand de gaulle avait fait cas d'une
heure le traité de l'élysée 63 après au
moment de la ratification le bundestag
avait ajouté un préambule qui disait
exactement ça est ce que les américains
s'étaient mis en colère contre ce traité
franco-allemand lancé curieux qu elle l
est pas bougé du tout et c'est pas
exactement ce que dit madame merkel
c'est parce que dit madame dhalla yann
qui parle d'une commission géopolitique
bon donc le pignon allemands ont peu
bougé par rapport à ça mais il faut
noter que c'est très très difficile
parce qu'il nous sorte d'inertie de
léthargie son jeu politique de la part
des européens qui espèrent pouvoir
continuer avec cette protection
américaine
mais c'est pas au niveau des enjeux des
défis dont on le monde tel qu'il est
alors peut alors c'est vrai que les
avertissant c'était votre remarque
trente membres allemands par ses
provocations aurait dû encourager ce
mouvement mais qui n'a pas été très loin
donc avec by dane faudra ils ont
enregistré utiliser au mieux les
changements positifs
j'en ai site est plein
mais ne pas se contenter d'un
soulagement du genre le cauchemar trump
est finie donc faudra faire des
propositions et c'est donc lancer
quelque chose en europe d'un qu'on
retombe cela change quoi le monde sait
pas si simple et je crois que vous
faites partie d'un groupe d'experts qui
est chargé de réfléchir un peu à
l'avenir de l'otan justement quand on
quand on voit ces déclarations de la
ministre allemande de la défense verrou
doit aller l'otan dans ce rapport entre
les états unis et l'europe
je peux pas vous en parler parce qu'il y
est une consigne de secret dont le
groupe est aussi en effet le français
désigné par le président macron pour
réfléchir à l'avenir de l'otan des 10 il
ya trente pays
on travaille sur un rapport qui sera
remis aux ministres des pays de l'otan
début décembre de ce rapport il ya
clairement un dangereux un enjeu de
souveraineté européenne aujourd'hui on
l'a vu donc avec donald trump
on le voit aussi aujourd'hui avec la
crise sanitaire mondiale et vous en
parlait justement dans votre dernier
livre dont on va voir la couverture et
s'intitule et après il est paru en juin
du 11 juin dernier vous évoquez le monde
donc d'après la pandémie à quoi doit
ressembler l'europe dans le monde
d'après selon vous quel est le défi
principal qu'elle doit relever et pas
spécialement l'europe
c'est un lieu de réflexion
anthropologique sur bon vous avez vous
abordé différents n'est jamais arrivé
que l'humanité tout entière est pure de
la même chose en même temps et donc
j'analyse qui va changer en bien ou en
mal ce qu'il devrait changer pas la même
chose
selon les décisions qui sont prises mais
l'europe n'est pas la seule réponse
d'ailleurs les braults proches contre
l'europe était infondée ce qu'il retient
pas de compétence sanitaires et même au
plus fort de la pandémie voyez pas de
peuples en europe qui disent qu il
vaudrait dans l'avenir que je suis un
commissaire européen qui est règle tout
ça n'existe pas donc les gens se
tournent vers le maire vers la région
vers le gouvernement vers l'état nation
rien comme une vraie question qui se
pose sur la circulation des personnes
au niveau de l'espace schengen en
période de pandémie c'est un problème
mondial ça d'ailleurs la cia et bill
gates et autres cas les prévenus prévu
tout ça
il dit ça par intra inévitablement
quelque part parce que la déforestation
des confine les virus intégré saint lô
complètement changé des politiques
agricoles mondiales par une politique
d'écologisation et ses terres faut se
préparer à l'arrière de retrouver virus
du type oui c'est ce que disent les
virologues en tout cas donc après tout
le monde circule tout le monde circule
parce que l'humanité est agitée d'une
sorte de mouvement de revient alors
normalement à l'intérieur de schengen
même si les règles sont suspendus en ce
moment on peut circuler facilement le
président macron vient de dire à juste
titre et pour d'autres raisons et c'est
la sécurité et qu'il fallait repenser
schengen ça c'est évident ça bon donc le
problème de la pandémie séquelles remis
en cause sur beaucoup de points
l'idée qu'on s'était fait de la
mondialisation tels que les élites et
les classes moyennes supérieures
on fait ce qu'on veut on va où on veut
quand on veut et sait on est obligé un
petit peu de réguler tout ça donc il y
aura des leçons à tirer
mais le petit livre que qui est un petit
livre ça se dit en une heure en fait moi
je conclus surtout sur la dimension
écologique et pas l'écologie au sens
statique nu au sens politique écologique
comme on le voit en europe 1 - vaste
mouvement mondial scientifique raisonnée
d'écologisation de tous agriculture
industrie transport etc etc et la
commande comment c'est possible ça parce
que pour aller vers un mode de
production démarrer mais comment comment
est-ce qu'on peut aller vers ça dans un
monde où la seule boussole reste le
profit enfin c'est le principe quand
même un peu le coin de la compagnie
tchèque le profit by gens qui vont faire
des fortunes avec les batteries de
l'avenir le profit n'interrompt pas
forcément les critères environnementaux
on va vers le moins cher et pas
forcément vers le plus vert oui il ya
des obligations de changements
techniques
d'ailleurs le bilan écologique des pays
communistes étaient bien pires
y a pas de lien automatique entre disons
capitalisme surtout la vision pendant 20
ans france donc on voit bien que dans le
monde entier
par exemple le plus grand fonds de
retraite au monde que le norvégien a
décidé de sortir des énergies non
renouvelables largement financiers les
gens qui investissent des fortunes dans
les voitures électriques
c'est en train d'évoluer beaucoup plus
vite que prévu les gens qui investissent
dans les cimenteries d'aujourd'hui
qu'ils recyclent 98% des faits ce qu'il
fallait rejeter avant donc le système
productif mondiale est beaucoup plus
avancé qu'on ne le croit évidemment il
ya des entreprises des pays qui veulent
gagner du temps c'est comme les
conducteurs diligence ils sont pas
content de l'arrivée du très bon et des
choses comme ça mais il s'est beaucoup
plus vous dénoncez pas avancer au même
point mais progressivement les débats
sur l'écologie ça va devenir un débat
sur le rythme auquel reboot on va
écologistes et voyez à quel rythme avec
l acceptabilité aussi parce que voilà il
ya quand même du radier il y aura des
milliers de cas différents mais s'il
revient ou 30 ans ça va seul s'imposer
et quand il ya on nous dira comme disent
les producteurs betteraves mais nous
aussi on abandonne les néocotinoïdes la
moitié de la récolte est perdue on a dit
bon on comprend aujourd'hui
mais qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire don
en deux ans dans cinq ans dix ans il n'y
a pas plus de recherche bon mais ça
c'est une approche très scientifique de
l'écologie mais dans le monde entre il
ya des millions de gens
des millions de gens qui sont là dessus
chercheurs inventeurs scientifiques
chefs d'entreprise de stains c'est quoi
le bon schéma pour la france pour aller
vers cette politique d'écologisation
vous le décrivez dans votre livre vous
allez beaucoup de tous les français
notre entreprise extraordinaire non dans
les domaines de l'eau la propreté du
recyclage etc
énormément de chercheurs de talent
malheureusement depuis vingt ou trente
ans il ya beaucoup de mathématiciens
géniaux les qui partait en californie
parce qu'on n'en proposait rien ici donc
on allait beaucoup d'éléments humains
beaucoup d'éléments et scientifique
il faut corriger la principale
aberration c'est que les écologistes
beaucoup d'entre eux sincèrement
d'ailleurs se sont concentrés que contre
le nucléaire sous l' influence des verts
allemands qui étaient horrifiés par la
politique en effet nucléaire américaine
alors donc donc ça s'est étendu et c'est
un contresens absolu
comme le la priorité c'est la sphère du
climat donc le co2 comme le nucléaire
n'émet pas de co2 donc faut vraiment
revenir à l'idée que l'on se passera du
nucléaire des concours 1 et quand par
exemple le solaire sur un rentable à
grande échelle où il est mais que ie
commencé par fermer du nucléaire comme
on l'a fait a écrit ce naïve ça veut
dire que du coup on oublie de faire des
coupures de courant
on est obligé de relancer dès la ligue
street avec le charbon c'est extravagant
c'est ce qu'a fait l'allemagne
une quinzaine d'années c'est une
aberration il faut commencer par sortir
du charbon puis tatatata mans donc il ya
une approche ça fait partie de
l'écologisation scientifiques sur la
scène internationale vous plaidez pour
un retour en vrai multilatéralisme dans
le domaine de la santé mais on sait
jamais le terme alors le thème c'est un
système non parce que c'était latéral ou
sur le ms vous
selon sam coopération internationale oui
ça me semble possible avec la chine avec
la russie de poutine sur logique après
tout et l'oeil nu été créé il y avait
lieu de staline ou qu'on n'arriverait
pas mais non mes moyens principe de
réalité qui va s'imposer à toutes les
puissances ont rejoint la réalité finit
par s'imposer à tout le monde mais il ya
tellement d'idéologie de fantasmes
d'approximations en tout cas moi je jan
aps la patrouille multilatéralise de ce
que c'est devenu une sorte de religion
rien comme si trump et l horrible type
qui avait détruit le multilatéralisme et
même avant clinton il disait moi je veux
bien réglé les premiers que les alliés
si ça marche pas je décide tout seul
voilà il ya même les pays les plus hard
disons les plus ardents défenseurs du
multilatéralisme ne le sont jamais
complètement
peut-être la suisse de notre ami
journaliste qu'on a entendu teneur mais
et les autres pays n'ont ils sont
mutilés l'intérieur en partie il préfère
coopérer quand ça marche
donc il faut regarder montré il faut pas
évoqué de bill clinton tu donnes une
religion contre l'hérésie trump yens il
faut démontrer que c'est utile pour tout
le monde de remettre en marche l'om est
ce que les états unis ils reviennent et
que dans ce cas d'en face une évolution
une panne en excuser moi une dévaluation
mondial de toutes les politiques menées
depuis le début de la pandémie pour voir
ce qui est utile de faire pour après
c'est un exemple et l'accord de paris
c'est très important ça suffit pas il
faut un investissement scientifique
colossal en plus donc je suis très
partisan des coopérations
internationales
mais il faut pas que ça faut pas penser
que sa dispense les gouvernements
nationaux de leurs responsabilités oui
il faut pas dire ah c'est pas moi c'est
l'europe c'est pas moi c'est l'onu c'est
pas moi c'est la gorgue paris tu vaux
vraiment que ça engage et les
responsabilités mais c'est pas le
multilatéralisme dans tous les cas de
figure la france elle-même à la sa
dissuasion nucléaire
elle a sa propre armée là ses propres
décisions
l'allemagne aussi tout le monde et pour
conclure quel regard vous portez sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire liée
justement à cette pandémie en france
je me refuse à porter un regard
particulier sur la france parce qu'il
faudra voir regard mondiale de tous les
gouvernements de toutes les institutions
les trois quarts des gouvernements du
monde se sont adaptés tant bien que mal
en fait et puis ta tony corrige pas
évident c'est quand même un virus très
compliqué et des rebondissements étrange
les seuls pays qui s'en sort vraiment
bien sont très peu nombreux il ya 200
pays où n'a changé ni justement il ya
même pas dix pays qui s'en sortent bien
depuis le début et on sait pas forcément
la chine qui a éradiqué par des procédés
très brutaux elle est vous dire oui mais
c'est pas forcément la démocratie qu'ils
en ont la corée du sud s'en sort très
bien
la corée du sud s'en sort même mieux que
la chine en fait
et justement il faudra le gagner ça
tient à coire avoir votre avis
évidemment la discipline collective il
n'est pas besoin de réglementer tout
pour commencer on jurerait l'habitude de
porter le masque il ya le souvenir du
strass ils ont anticipé et donc c'est
plus facile dans ce genre de société
n'est ce pas c'est pas forcément des
régimes communistes
il yad'autres alors il ya des régimes
communistes qui sont qui ont bien réagi
comme le vietnam singapour qui entre les
deux qui s'est pas mal débrouillé et il
ya cinq six pays qui ont bien réagi
faudra regarder ce qui s'est passé dans
ces pays pour en tirer des leçons pour
tout le monde après donc faut pas se
focaliser même si on est dans le moment
le
le plus pénible mais bon c'est bien un
peu inquiétant faut pas se focaliser que
sur la france
quand j'ai parlé d'évaluation je ne
parle pas des règlements de compte
internes et procédures dans en justice
lancées contre des ministres en exercice
en ce moment je trouve ça scandaleux
on n'a aucun rapport trois ouvriers ces
dérèglements qui ça sert à rien ça fait
pas partie d'un principe de contrôle de
l'action publique
il faut le faire après d'accord ne le
fait pas en pleine bataille et qu'est-ce
qui peut imaginer ça par contre dans
l'évaluation après d'angie noël mais ce
peut être lancée grâce à notre ami ben
haida n'enverra c'est très important de
se mettre d'accord sur la surveillance
la larme la transparence dans la
formation
le confinement qu'est ce qui marche qui
marchent pas les tests les déconfinement
via une évaluation de tout y compris ce
qui va venir maintenant c'est à dire la
d'utilisation des vaccins et qui
peut-être vont arriver qui peut être
vont protéger juin les c'est à dire
après ça merci beaucoup vers red wings
venaient sur le plateau de ça vous
regarde rappel le titre de votre dernier
ouvrage et après paru chez fayard aux
interrogations d'interrogation à
l'antenne que s'est il passé à
l'assemblée
aujourd'hui on va voir cela dans la
chronique de thomas des prêts est thomas
ce soir vous nous parler du rôle des
citoyens pour fabriquer la loi de demain
oui bonsoir clermont c'est vrai que
depuis plusieurs semaines les
initiatives se multiplient pour faire
rentrer plus de démocratie participative
ici au parlement mais qu'en pensent les
députés je vous raconte
[Musique]
alors la place des citoyens c'est un
sujet qui revient souvent ici à
l'assemblée
et cette semaine ce sont les députés
socialistes et apparentés qui veulent
proposer à des français la possibilité
de fabriquer leurs prochains textes de
loi bonjour boris vélo alors racontez
nous cette proposition quelle est elle
écoutez c'est une proposition qu'on a
appelée l'aide individuelle à
l'émancipation qui consiste en une
notation de 5000 euros pour tous les
jeunes
on verra à 18 ans pour investir dans son
capital personnel c'est-à-dire dans sa
formation dans ces mobilités le passage
du permis de conduire l'acquisition d'un
premier véhicule
et puis ensuite un revenu de base ouvert
à 18 ans qui est rsa prix une activité
fusionner une forme de minimum jeunesse
comme il existe un minimum vieillesse et
comment vous allez demander l'avis aux
citoyens sur cette proposition là et
bien nous avons choisi la plateforme
parlement et citoyens que d'une civic
tech pour proposer aux citoyens de
débattre de chacun des aspects de cette
proposition de loi qui sera débattue en
février prochain dans l'antre niche
parlementaire et comment vous comptez
prendre en compte leur avis et bien
certaines propositions viendront
enrichir notre notre texte d'autres bas
nous ne reprenons pas notre compte mais
les plus plébiscités néanmoins nous
proposons que 1 des parlementaires soit
une forme de rapporteurs de ces
amendements citoyens nous expliquerons
pourquoi nous n'avons pas retenu et ils
pourront être débattues alors au fond ça
n'a rien de vraiment nouveau ce n'est
pas la première fois que des politiques
propose aux citoyens de fabriquer la loi
à leurs côtés on peut prendre l'exemple
de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat ou encore de la plate forme le
jour d'après lancé par plusieurs
parlementaires pendant le premier
confinement mais le sujet bas il divise
encore est ce que les députés n'ont pas
peur que les français attendent de les
remplacer a pas du tout moi je pense
qu'il faut vraiment qu'on construire
avec les citoyens n'y a pas d'opposition
entre démocratie représentative et
démocratie participative
au contraire elles se renforcent l'une
l'autre et il faut que ça devienne
vraiment un réflexe pour tous les
députés
c'est une forme d'atténuation de système
représentatif et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de dire au moment des débats sur le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne ou le
reprendre le référendum d'initiative
partagée que je pensais que ce n'était
pas
une voix satisfaisante de la démocratie
voilà clément il n'y a pas que les
groupes qui propose aux citoyens de
participer à la vie parlementaire
l'assemblée nationale le fait aussi
ils ont ouvert une plate forme pour
recueillir les signatures pour des
pétitions citoyennes depuis un mois
merci thomas c'est l'heure de notre face
à face à présent revoir les règles de
schengen renforcer les contrôles aux
frontières de l'europe la droite le
réclame depuis longtemps et bien
emmanuel macron aussi désormais le chef
de l'état a lancé cet appel aujourd'hui
une semaine après l'attentât de nice qui
a été commis par un tunisien qui étaient
entrés clandestinement en europe via
lampedusa en italie alors avant de
débattre de tout cela on va répondre à
quelques questions très concrètes 1
qu'est-ce que l'espace schengen
pourquoi est-il sous le feu des
critiques on voit cela avec marion
becker s'est depuis le perthus à la
frontière franco espagnole qu emmanuel
macron a appelé à la transformation de
cette espace de libre échange
créée en 1985 par les accords de
schengen je suis favorable et je
porterai en ce sens des premières
propositions au conseil de décembre à ce
que nous refusions en profondeur
schengen pour en repenser l'organisation
pour intensifier notre protection
communes aux frontières avec une
véritable police de sécurité aux
frontières extérieures de l'espace en
renforçant aussi l'intégration de nos
règles quel pays font partie de l'espace
schengen 26 pays forment cet espace 22
des 27 états membres de l'union
européenne plus l'islande la norvège la
suisse et le liechtenstein 400 millions
de personnes jouissent de cette espace
de libre circulation
une fois entré dans la zone schengen un
voyageur peut franchir les frontières et
se déplacer avec une simple carte
d'identité sans subir de contrôles les
vols aériens entre villes de l'espace
schengen sont considérés comme des vols
intérieurs
quelles sont alors les frontières
contrôler seuls les frontières
extérieures de l'espace schengen sont
contrôlées depuis 2004 l agence frontex
aide les états membres de l'union
européenne et de l'espace schengen à
sécuriser leurs frontières
un état ne peut rétablir les contrôles à
ses frontières intérieures qu en cas
d'atteinte à l'ordre public ou à la
sécurité nationale
après consultation des autres états du
groupe schengen
pourquoi shenzhen et qu'il régulièrement
remise en cause
en absence de politique migratoire
européenne certains pays n'ont pas les
moyens d'assurer le contrôle des
frontières extérieures notamment depuis
2015 et la crise migratoire qui a jeté
des dizaines de milliers de migrants aux
portes de l'espace c'est le cas en grèce
en matière de terrorisme
l'espace schengen montre aussi ses bons
mis l'europe at-elle les moyens
d'empêcher les terroristes qui veulent
la frapper sur son territoire le
terroriste tunisien qui a tué trois
fidèles à nice avait réussi à gagner la
france depuis la tunisie via l'île
italienne de lampedusa
c'est dans ce contexte qu'est manuel
mâcon s'est exprimé et pour débattre de
ce sujet j'accueille en plateau isabelle
florennes bonsoir vous êtes député modem
des hauts-de-seine et pierre henri
dumont bonsoir vous êtes des banques et
les républicains du pas de calais ont
commencé avec vous elisabeth florennes
quand on regarde le cas du terroriste
tunisien donc de nice les autorités
italiennes avaient ordonné son expulsion
son retour en tunisie seulement elles
n'ont pas expulser tout simplement parce
qu'elles sont débordées par l'afflux de
migrants sur leur territoire comment
peut-on répondre à ce problème qui ne se
pose pas que pour l'italie
il se pose depuis déjà un moment et
l'europe a déjà répondu en a en deux ans
d'otan frontex de moyens supplémentaires
l'année dernière puisqu'il ya quand même
eu dix mille postes aux frontières qui
ont été déployés sur l'ensemble des
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne et notamment en italie parce
que c'était une demande des italiens et
en grèce mais sait on voit bien que
c'est pas suffisant on voit bien qu'il
faut une politique migratoire coordonnée
au niveau de l'union européenne le
président de la république c'est pas
nouveau le réclame le problème c'est que
il faut discuter avec des états
qui veulent bien discuter de ces sujets
sur la question de lampedusa sur la
question des frontières italiennes
le précédent ministre de l'intérieur
avait commencé à vouloir négocier des
accords sur l'île de malte souvenez-vous
l'année dernière il y avait ce sujet qui
était déjà pendant on n'a pas pu aboutir
maintenant la bonne nouvelle c'est que
sous la pression effectivement d'une
menace terroriste plus importante des
questions migratoires et de cette
pression mais sur un certain nombre
d'états européens les choses ont peut
être changé c'est ce que nous espérons
et la présidente de la commission
européenne lorsque l'album dalian a pris
les choses en main il faut que ça bouge
il faut qu'on ait une politique
migratoire coordonnées et des moyens
supplémentaires à nos frontières mais
cette politique c'est une politique qui
est sur la base d'une négociation entre
états membres
donc d'une volonté des différents états
de bouger notamment de l'allemagne puis
henri dumont vous partagez ce diagnostic
sévère ya pas assez de moyens peut-être
sur frontex mais surtout il n'y a pas
encore vraiment de volonté partagée de
déployer une politique migratoire
commune il faut une double volonté foule
volonté européenne c'est ce que déjà
nous en 2014 nous avions dit avec
nicolas sarkozy nous avions annoncé
qu'il fallait un schengen 2 à l'époque
emmanuel macron été ministre de françois
hollande et tout le gouvernement
socialiste m'avait dit pis que pendre
cette proposition je m'aperçois
aujourd'hui qu'on n'avait pas forcément
tort de le prononcer de dire ainsi je
m'aperçois qu'ils emmanuel macron même
depuis qu'il est président a changé
d'avis sur schengen ils étaient en
roumanie au début de son mandat
expliquant qu'il devait intégrer et que
la roumanie devait intégrer l'espace
schengen donc aujourd'hui on voit qu'il
fait volte-face
mais il ya l'aspect européen qui va
prendre du temps des années
s'il ya un accord il ya l'aspect
national ses mains des années en a on à
la lande reggae qui peut être assez
rapprochés il faut la collection nord il
vous faudra l'accord de tivoli le sujet
dès le prochain conseil européen de
décembre bien mais il faudra au moins
des mois voire des années pour arriver à
un nouvel accord c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne pour tous les accords sait
pas que sur une question migratoire tous
les accords européens il faut sauver
leur est dû à limiter son arrivée de
tierces mais règle majorité on peut
rappeler quand même l'échéance que s'est
fixé emmanuel macron dans la déclaration
qu'il a faite aujourd'hui il a dit qu'il
espérait finaliser cette réforme est
remise à plat des accords de schengen
est bon premier semestre
1022 lors de la présidence française de
l'union européenne c'est quand même pas
leur tri de suite au minimum un an il le
vit aussi faire et il l'a posée
aujourd'hui mais on l'avait posée avant
c'est un an pendant les européennes
rappelez vous sa cccd politique qu'on
doit coordonner et là dessus on nous
n'avions pas d'accord notamment de
l'allemagne pour les frontières et la
question italienne donc le renforcement
des moyens de frontex c'était un premier
pas important sous la présidence d
manueel mâcon moi je veux dire que sur
ces questions-là ses 35 ans les accords
de schengen
on peut aussi se renvoyer la balle je ne
sais pas si nicolas samedi non plus dans
ses rangs la politique migratoire oui on
expulse est deux fois plus grand et du
plus que vous ne le fait on délivrait
50% de type de séjour en moins c'est les
chiffres on n'est pas l'immigration faut
il taira remis en cause j'étais assez
belge de brice hortefeux salue du
ministère de l'intérieur bon écouter
pour les bras car vous avez le droit est
loin d'être une trump française honore
les chiffres qu'ils sont sermonnés en
aller vérifier moi ce que je vous dis
simplement en totalité embryon de
politique européenne d'un côté une
politique nationale de l'autre je suis
d'accord avec vous il ne faut pas qu'il
y ait de disparités entre les pays mais
ça veut pas dire qu'on doit tout
attendre de leur appui aussi les
politiques nationales que nous pouvons
mettre en place et quand je vois sur
l'église seront proposés quoi on vous
propose est très simple sur la question
du droit d'asile on sait qu'aujourd'hui
le droit d'asile et des voiliers en
france où on à 151 mille demandeurs
d'asile qui sont arrivés en france et
qui ont fait leur demande en 2019
deuxième pays plus forte augmentation de
ces cinq dernières années on a
aujourd'hui un tiers de ces demandes
d'asile 50 milles environ qui viennent
de personnes qui ont déjà été déboutés
de leur demande d'asile
ailleurs en europe et du de la france a
parfaitement le droit de dire je
n'examine pas ses demandes d'asile où je
décide de mettre en procédure accélérée
se demande d'asile qui emboliser demande
sympa fait quand on parle et vous pensez
que la hong lei directeur sorbonne
examine ces demandes d'asile sur les
mêmes critères que la france dans ces
cas là dans ces cas là il faut il faut
suivre la proposition qui était la
proposition de nicolas sarkozy en 2014 à
laquelle emmanuel macron avait dit non
et en ministre du françois hollande à
l'époque je le rappelle qui est où nous
ont expliqué qu'il fallait évidemment
une europe
à plusieurs vitesses avec plusieurs
cercles et faire en sorte que en effet
sur certains points ce ne sommes pas
d'accord sur par exemple les critères
d'attribution de l'asile dans ces cas là
il faut qu'on travaille avec moins de
pays sur ces critères là ça avait été
rejetée à l'époque on avait eu raison a
priori six ou sept ans elle avance et
bien tant mieux qu'aujourd'hui soit
repris ce que je voudrais dire également
c'est par exemple on a eu un ministre de
l'intérieur gérard collomb qui
expliquait que les migrants faisait du
benchmark
alors si je reprends ses terres a
expliqué qu'elle est bonne ça veut dire
que d'après gérard collomb moi je ne
fais que cinterion
il disait que les migrants les filières
de réseaux de migrants comparer les
avantages sociaux de tel ou tel pays les
rapidité d'exécution des demandes
d'occulter f pour ce qui concerne la
france oméga lotto d'allocation de
demandeurs d'asile et moi ce que je vois
c'est que en allemagne pour un même
demandeurs d'asile on a un taux de
protection qui est par exemple pour les
afghans deux fois inférieur à ce que
fait la france
évidemment ça pose un problème et la
même façon la location de proment
d'heure d'asile et 25% supérieur en
allemagne qui est de lait en france donc
un an donné c'est aussi à nous
d'harmoniser un auto de protection avec
l'allemagne parce que vous faisiez
référence est l'allemagne en quarts les
rues politique européenne de définir de
livrer la location pour demandeurs
d'asile se définit les cliques et
laissez vous répondez sur ce point après
france ne fait rien d'abord on ne fait
pas rien puisque les moyens ont été
annoncées notamment aujourd'hui par le
président de la république du doublement
des effectifs de s'emporter et
doublement et ça c'est vers là france
contrôler ses frontières depuis les
montagnes les villes côtières qui pose
problème c'est à dire l'italie on le
sait depuis longtemps et les moyens
avaient déjà été renforcés à la
frontière italienne et les moyens
renforcés depuis les annonces de ce soir
à la frontière espagnole c'est quand
même important s'il faut le dire et le
président de la république en a
parfaitement conscience sur la question
des politiques migratoires qu'aux
coordonnées on est toujours sur la même
chose je suis d'accord sur les critères
de droit d'asile
ça sera négocié au niveau européen mais
il veut manger
il nous reste avant la fin de cette
émission j'ai envie quand même qu'on
aborde un autre point de la déclaration
des manuels macron aujourd'hui il fait
un lien entre immigration clandestine et
terrorisme en évoquant des passerelles
entre les réseaux de trafiquants et les
réseaux terroristes excusez moi c'est
nouveau dans sa bouche mais regardez la
réaction immédiate que ça a déclenché
avec ce message qui a été postée par
marine le pen
il y a donc bien un lien entre
immigration anarchique et insécurité
soyons sérieux suspendons schengen c'est
trop facile
sur les trente terroristes en quelques
mois parce que j'aimerais aussi entendre
car henry de mort il a déjoué depuis le
début du mandat d' emmanuel macron une
trentaine d'attentats ça fait quasiment
un attentat par mois des jouets
depuis le démarrage de mandat par le les
équipes et par le ministère de
l'intérieur il faut le rappeler donc il
ya une politique anti terroriste qui
fonctionne quoi qu'on en dise même si on
se retrouve dans cette situation juste
pour dire le ministre nous a reprécisé
ça au début de la semaine sur les trente
terroristes
22 sont français 22 sont très vite et
juste en quelques secondes il faut
suspendre schengen de facto ils sont
suspendus puisque ça fait cinq ans que
nous avons des comptes hier des
contrôles aux frontières intérieures de
l'union européenne c'est-à-dire la
frontière franco espagnole à la
frontière franco-italienne la réalité je
suis désolé mais c'est que gérald
darmanin nous dit il n'y a pas de lien
entre immigration et terrorisme emmanuel
macron nous dit aujourd'hui il y a un
lien entre immigration et terrorisme qui
se mettent d'accord
merci beaucoup à tous les deux est venu
sur le plateau de ça vous regarde
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve demain pour un nouveau numéro
de ça vous regarde tout de suite votre
soirée documentaire très belle soirée
sur lcp
[Musique]